i mean how much were you salivating at
the opportunity of a fight with nate
diaz
when when dana started saying that maybe
they had just released him and then he
suggested the fight i mean dana yeah
dana said he said that's the fight um
and
i think
you know if dana wants to let that
happen
then i'm down tell me that's a massive
thing i mean that's not the biggest one
two million pay-per-views right there
easily and
i think it's a good fight as well
yeah a
really competitive fight and it'll be
interesting to test my skills and i i uh
i'll be excited for that obviously
he has one more fight or two more fights
or something under his contract one more
but they won't give it to him
why not make that the last fight is
going to talk [ __ ] about him i said to
dana that i will fight for free
against nate diaz all he has to do is
raise
the fighter pay minimum to 50k
and provide them healthcare and i'll
fight nate diaz for free as his last
fight mma that would come earlier we're
gonna fight him in mma and fight him in
the octagon in the ufc for free
hold on one second
would you let would you let dana white
put his big toe in your belly button no
same thing
hold on
fighters
for fighter pay dana white can touch my
belly button wow with his big toe yeah
that's big
that's big that's big
i don't think dana cares that much
because
that's big though the nate fight you
would do in mma
but can you even can you even grapple
and [ __ ] i i have a wrestling background
up until when though cause a lot of
people say i got a background but it's
like high school
up until the junior year of high school
the tricky thing about wrestling is that
like that's when jiu jitsu begins
so right like you're on the ground
just look at
the his last fight with leon edwards or
that might not have been yeah i think it
is his last fight and
it's virtually not on the ground at all
yeah um
and my striking
i think is better than nate diaz he goes
for a takedown
i [ __ ] sprawl and get out of it
you know
so i wouldn't be worried about that and
then i would just outstrike them
what weight
175 could you get down to 175 yeah
really yeah how do you walk around that
two
no like 196.
okay right now walking around 196 198
um
but could make it down to 175 for the
right money
yeah for the right money i mean he might
come up
with 170. so that i mean it makes sense
yeah do it at 175. why not do the boxing
match
i think people want the boxing back i
think that the mma fight
i think the mma fight is people would
see you at too much of a disadvantage
i think boxing people want to see
the people who don't like you want to
see you get exposed right that's the
whole idea oh this guy's gonna beat jake
paul it was the same thing like this is
crazy to make the comparison but like
you know i'm a huge floyd fan and like
watching
watching what happened with floyd like
people are paying money to see him lose
and he made so much [ __ ] money yeah
not in terms of skill maybe but in terms
of i
this guy's so good at playing the
villain i want to pay to see him lose
yeah which again is genius i think
that's the perfect thing and then nate
everybody's like oh nate's got good
striking maybe nate could be the guy to
do it you have this cool riff with mma
that's a massive [ __ ] fight tommy
stay in england
yeah but for me it's about
fighting the professional boxer and you
wanna shut that crowd up yeah like yo
you gave me a professional boxer and i
knocked them the [ __ ] out yeah now i'll
fight nade diaz but they're already
preparing for that like i see he's gonna
do it eddie hearn doing that you see
what he said recently where he's like uh
now on paper you know tommy should beat
jake but tommy's not good at boxing
either so it's like you're already
discrediting
your own fighter it's like
yeah it's like when drake drops this
recent album fire by the way it's it's
[ __ ] great
thank you the [ __ ] internet that's
the straightest thing you've said on
this podcast
[ __ ]
idiots just compiled together because
they have nothing else to do and they
start hating on it yeah but the album
goes number one the the jimmy cook song
goes on goes number one on billboard and
it's like people are playing the song
every single day so drake could be at
the he's the best artist in the world
the greatest of all time and everyone
still wants to critique him there's
always going to be that crowd there and
it's just that's what it's going to be
for me when i beat tommy fury and i beat
the professional boxer it'll never be
enough they'll be like okay we'll now
fight a world champion but that goes
against what you just said which is i
want to fight tommy to shut them up then
you just said they'll never shut up but
but they'll they'll have to respect it
and eat their own words of like well
when he fights around he can't say yeah
exactly they can't say he can't beat a
boxer yeah no exactly and and
of course eddie hearn is already
preparing his ex dude he's preparing it
yeah that's what he does he's a he's a
weasel he's a snake
snake guy right there okay going on this
it's like
this seems like a good clip
[Laughter]
we're getting the title all right
this is good for youtube yeah yeah
what do you mean he's a weasel
hey guys
i'm in the flagrant group
oh